- A lot of your favorite
RNB and dance tunes
have killer background vocals
that you might not have
noticed on your first listen.
Just check out the harmonies in the chorus
of Ariana Grande's "Thank U, Next."
♪ Thank u, next ♪
♪ Next ♪
♪ Thank u ♪
In this episode, we're going to dive
into the world of background vocals,
and I'm even gonna break
down how I write vocals
for my own music.
♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
I have been a musician
pretty much my whole life,
but I never intended to be
a professional musician.
And by that, I mean I never thought
that I could even really
afford to have a music career
and have that be the thing
that I do for my job.
(people laughing)
Music was always a constant in my life.
It's interesting to me now.
I wouldn't have assumed that
I would become an RnB singer.
And I think a big part of
that is going to Oberlin,
which is where my music
career really started.
I was asked to perform in an RnB showcase,
and I sang a couple of Kehlani songs.
I was a huge Kehlani fan.
And "No scrubs," which I still perform
at almost all my shows. (laughs)
♪ Hanging out the passenger side ♪
And I think that experience
really opened my eyes
because I was able to see
that I could be an artist
and I could be an artist in this field
without having the music experience
that I was taught I needed to have.
This next song is called
"Green Tea Ice Cream."
One of my songs that has
backing vocals that I love
is "Green Tea Ice Cream."
The sounds that I came up with
just felt like they belonged there.
And I didn't want another
instrument to play that part,
so I made my voice the
instrument to play the part.
♪ By the sea ♪
♪ Sweatshirts sweatpants ♪
♪ White noise blue jeans ♪
Vocal layering has been
a musical tradition
of cultures around the globe
for thousands of years.
Prehistoric hunters in Africa and Asia
are known to have used polyphonic singing,
which is where individual vocalists
sing unique phrases and notes together.
In ancient Greece, a chorus
was a group of singers
that would describe the
action of a play through song.
And during the Middle Ages,
organum described one or more voices
accompanying a main melody chant.
Today, backing vocals are an
essential part of popular music
and are used to give
tracks energy and depth.
Background vocals in genres like RnB
often include two or more layers
of the same note in unison
in order to give the
vocals a fuller effect.
This is often referred to as doubling.
You can hear this in the
verse of "What You Did,"
where the second half
of each line is doubled.
♪ And I know you know ♪
♪ I've been holding guard
for so long, so long ♪
And in rap music, lyricists
often use doubled vocals
to highlight keywords at
the end of each phrase.
♪ Focus on the picture in front of me ♪
♪ You as clear as DVD
on digital TV screens ♪
Vocal lyrics in the chorus or
hook often include harmonies.
Unlike unison vocals,
harmonies use two or more
notes simultaneously.
♪ Call me when you want ♪
♪ Call me when you need ♪
♪ Call me in the morning
♪ ♪ I'll be on the way ♪
RnB artists will sometimes
use three-part harmonies
to give the vocals the
fullness of a whole cord.
♪ One wants fool's love ♪
♪ That kind of messy love ♪
Sometimes I think something
like a voice is a lot softer
than something like a brass instrument
or even a full quartet
if I think that's something beautiful.
There's just something so vulnerable
about using your own voice.
And I also think that it keeps the track
very light and ethereal while
still adding depth to it
and making it feel full.
So here's an example
of a two-part harmony.
♪ Ooh, whoa ♪
And then this is an example
of a three-part harmony.
♪ Ah, ah ♪
There is one line in the background vocal
like the one that I just
sang that I want to stick out
more than the rest of
the background vocal.
So I wanna make sure that
that line stays consistent
so that I can lower the rest
of the background vocals
if that's what I need to do.
So that's just all part
of texture and balance.
♪ Ooh, whoa ♪
♪ Ah, ah ♪
That brings us to ad libs,
short for ad libitum,
which generally means
with freedom in Latin.
This is where the lead
singer improvises a melody,
usually over the course of the song.
For example, in "He Wasn't Man Enough,"
Toni Braxton is improvising new lyrics
on top of the original melody.
♪ Do you know about us back
then? ♪ ♪ Calling me all along ♪
♪ Do you know I dumped your husband ♪
♪ Begging me ♪
The ad libs are clearly the lead vocal
and not the background.
However, these days, ad libs also refer
to the improvised lines
added to hip hop tracks
after the main vocals are recorded.
♪ With my Timbs on ♪
♪ How many championships ♪
♪ What, six rings on ♪
This is to compliment the lead vocal
and even create a countermelody.
The last background vocal
we have for this section
is an ad lib which is my favorite.
♪ Ooh, whoa ♪
Ah, so good.
Singers often add call and
response to repeated choruses
in order to give the section
more variety and emotional energy.
♪ Like how can I ♪
♪ How do I manage expectations ♪
So in this part of the song,
you can hear one of the main
uses of call and response.
And the way that I used it in the song
is to finish the sentence.
So the sentence means one thing
when it's just the lead vocals,
but then when it's the background vocals,
it's kind of a finished thought.
When I perform "Green Tea Ice Cream" live,
I feel like it's so apparent
how important the background vocals are
because I don't always have the chance
to perform it with other singers.
So that is one of my songs
that if I have the chance,
I always perform it with
background vocalists.
Backing vocalists are singers that provide
background harmonies or a
countermelody to the lead singer.
Before the invention of tape
recording in the 20th century,
it was impossible for the lead singer
to perform their own harmonies
or double their vocals
in a live performance.
♪ Sirens in the dark ♪
Those little moments are the moments
that I come up with first.
You know, like the little-
♪ Ooh ♪
- riffs come first
and then those long background
vocals and harmonies
that kind of tie the parts
together come second for me
because those are more instrumental,
and those kind of make me consider
the direction of the song
more than just this moment.
I want this moment to shine.
♪ Sweatshirts sweatpants ♪
♪ White noise blue jeans ♪
♪ Writing letters to old friends ♪
♪ Black cats and tender moments ♪
All the background vocals in this song
have an effect in the mixing process.
But right now they're just raw,
so it's gonna sound a
little bit differently
than it would sound once
the song is fully produced.
In the pop music realm, there
are often teams of people
working on individual tracks or albums.
Vocal producers are in charge
of coaching the recording artists
as well as arranging, editing, processing,
and mixing each take to perfection.
Many songwriters and singers
are capable of doing this job
on their own, but talented
industry favorite Kuk Harrell
has made a name for himself
by creating the background
and leading vocal magic
on hits songs featuring
stars like Rihanna, Beyonce,
and Justin Bieber.
Something I love about background vocals
is that you get to say things
that you didn't necessarily
get to stay in the lead vocals,
whether that's just because it doesn't fit
as well with the song or
it doesn't rhyme, maybe,
or it doesn't fit the theme as well,
or it's just like a little secret
for the people that are
really listening well,
or maybe what you were saying
was a little bit vulnerable
and you don't wanna put
it front and center.
So I love RnB because
I love how RnB vocals
are like normal line, like-
♪ You wronged me ♪
- and then the background vocals are like-
♪ I threw you things in the backyard ♪
That is the kind of background vocals
that I was growing up on.
So like Beyonce did that, Kelly Rowland.
They're the queens of that kind of shade
and Jazmine Sullivan, you know.
Even the vocal riffs,
the way that you riff,
I feel like you can tell
someone off with a vocal riff,
and I have.
Thanks for watching.
But before you go, we wanna hear from you.
What's your favorite track with
beautiful background vocals?
Record a video of yourself
responding to this question
and send it to us using the
link in the description,
and you might just see
yourself in our next episode.
(soft music)